okay um so I'm going to be talking about
audience research and the title of my
thesis is audience research respondent
and process rediscovering the value of
the television audience um so before we
start to get into the value of the
television audience I want to start by
telling two stories the first happens at
about this time last year the show chuck
which is on NBC was about to be canceled
and while Chuck had pretty low ratings
it had a very active fan base online and
those fans organized and instead of just
writing letters to NBC which is what
fans would usually do in this case um
these chats and organized online and
they decided to go directly to one of
the sponsors sort of the advertisers on
top um subway sandwiches so thousands of
chuck fans all over the world on one day
went into subway and Fox lat long
sandwiches they then wrote on comic
parts at the subway saying I love Trump
so much I'm really glad that you're
sponsoring Chuck please help to juggle
mayor or something to that effect um
they also wrote letters to subway
executives and two executives at NBC and
here this is a quote from one of the
saved Chuck websites the intent is to
let the network and their sponsor know
that we've received their message this
is something in Neilsen box can't do
this is the transition translation of
fan loyalty into real dollars that NBC
and subway can measure so these fans
were really smart they understood that
to both NBC and subway they were really
only valuable as people who buy
sandwiches so instead of just talking
about how much they love Chuck they made
themselves very visibly into people
combined sandwiches and it works NBC
kept Chuck on the air for another season
the fans and they also worked out a deal
with subway where subway is now a more
prominent sponsor because so we saw the
value of the science and wanted to get
more involved with jobs the second story
occurred at the same time last year at
the exact same network NBC and what
happened with NBC decided to forgo an
hour of scripted programming every
single week night at ten o'clock so
instead of having something scripted on
they decided that they were going to
have a talk show hosted by jay leno who
used to host the tonight show and now
post the tank show up again um in this
case is just almost a 180 from the way
the chuck audience was made valuable um
NBC basically ignored the cultural value
that anyone would have gotten from
something they put at ten o'clock and
gave everybody a whole bunch of Jay Leno
that they don't really want um there
isn't the reason they disses was because
producing a talk show is super super
cheap so even if the ratings were low
they could because their costs and you
can squeak out a little bit of profit by
putting jay leno on instead of an
expensive descriptive show unfortunately
because they ignore is the cultural
value that people get from programming
this plan backfired and this is one of
my favorite as many seen in reviews of
the jay leno show Nancy Franklin in New
Yorker wrote the forensic evidence so
far indicates that a kind of death is
taking place before our eyes nvq zaditor
attitude toward the jay leno show
signals a whole new level of
indifference resignation and laziness um
so by ignoring the reasons why people
watch TV and programming to their bottom
line NBC really messed this one up and
managed to create what you can see me
recalls number one the biggest TV bomb
ever so these two stories um illustrate
to me that there's something wrong with
the system in place that is making
audiences valuable
um both of these sort of went around the
system of meals and ratings to try and
make audiences valuable in a different
way you know in Chuck's case they were
trying to translate their cultural value
in into that space n NB C's case they
were just programming to their bottom
line rather than people so the first
issue this raises is what I'm calling a
crisis and innovation and i'm not
talking about technological innovation
technological innovation is actually
part of the problem but i think that
that is pretty much covered i'm really
talking about a crisis in innovating the
relationships that makes these business
models work so just briefly here are
sort of all the players on in the
television industry and that corner
there you got the TV audience this big
guy here in the middle is mr. Nielsen
himself started the business at meals
rating thank God advertisers represented
by man been here um and the networks on
the program this shows and that there's
the cable guy um so the weight of this
system is works traditionally is that
programmers create content that is then
distributed to audiences either some
cable or through broadcast or satellite
or whatever then the audiences are
measured by Nielsen so Nielsen
essentially takes take the audience
measures what it's doing and turns that
measurement into a currency that's
called ratings the networks and
subscribes Nielsen ratings then give me
open money and in return they get
ratings the networks and use those
ratings to the advertisers that the
advertisers use to decide where they're
going to place that you know depending
on what kind of audience so Nielsen here
you can see
new year and the reason I happen is that
Nielsen saw the need to create a
currency because it's the networks are
measuring their own audiences the
advertisers aren't necessarily going to
take their word for it because they
obviously have an incentive to you don't
make the audience's bigger and better
than they are I'm surreal sinister
exceptin is a neutral mediator the
problem is that with digital
distribution this system that that sort
of worked before doesn't work anymore
because all of a sudden TV doesn't just
look like that but it looks like this
we've got video on demand um this is
this south park full episode player you
can watch online this is a Facebook
stream next to a live stream of CNN with
that mobile TV and then like what
happens when people are doing all the
stuff at once all of a sudden is
currency the sport and the traditional
space doesn't work anymore so I'm
suggesting a few things to fix this
situation first the actual corporate
culture of these institutions needs to
change they need to reevaluate the
relationship now they're thinking
they're still thinking of television
like this so when a new model comes up
you know we have mobile TV or we have
online TV because that relationship so
complicated and took so long to develop
they're trying to just shove these new
things it's that old model but that
model was it was made for this and this
isn't what TV looks like anymore it's
digital now and like who's good at
digital things these guys so you've got
you know Sony making playstation making
internet-enabled TVs you have Amazon and
Netflix who are both really good at
making sense of data on ensuring that
data and helping
find it and then you've got Microsoft's
an apple which you know apple just
announced that they're starting an
advertising platform Microsoft's got one
Microsoft's also manufacturing hardware
like the Xbox so the challenge here with
these other industries is really twofold
first the television industry needs to
look at these businesses and see what
they're doing that the television
industry isn't doing and they also need
to see these guys it's viable
competitors because everyone on the
slide is getting into the TV business it
is threatening to do it better than the
current TV business so the first thing I
think needs to be examined um is if they
really need to find value in context
these are all valuable ways to watch
television but you know the mobile and
online is is different and it's not
better or worse but it's new enemies to
be looked at as a new site of value and
it needs to be understood as such
instead of just I'm trying to make these
things look exactly like TV the second
thing that needs to change is the role
of the mediator we have Nielsen here you
know who's trying really hard to get all
these data streams to make sense but
it's just not working with the old model
and this is a quote from the chief
Research Officer NBC and add age he said
this isn't just about television the
problem extends across all media
platforms and it's not about the lack of
data virtualization it more clear come
all of a sudden there are all these data
streams that the programmers needs to
make sense of and nielsen jump can't do
that anymore so what does a new mediator
look like you may have noticed that
Google was not on that other slide
because
here obviously Google has has pioneered
you know a different a different kind of
advertising model and Google is really
just one example of how this can work
but the value that Google really brings
to the equation is it while Nielsen
makes data well Nielsen takes what the
audience is doing and makes into a
currency Google does that but they also
make sense with the data so you know
they give people actionable actual
things and they also create a
marketplace where advertisers and
programmers can actually you know
interact with each other through google
no I'm not saying that that's
necessarily the answer but it is one way
to reevaluate role mediator given the
affordances of digital distribution so I
want to take a step back now and look at
back to the two stories the beginning I
think there's also a big problem in how
the audience is made valuable you know
we have the chuck audience that makes
itself valuable by bank sandwiches and
then the leno audience which innervates
even really exists but it's family will
because they lose the network money um
so I'm going to walk through a bunch of
assumptions instead of sort of evolved
in the television industry can sort of
push back against how these assumptions
work so the first assumption is that
consistency in the ratings currency is
more important than accuracy or more
important of even knowing what watching
is so when Nielsen rolled out there
people meters which is the box that sort
of like makes readings all these
families got people meters um and then
that was kind of it there was big study
done in 1992 and they found that
although they're given the
responsibility the Nielsen family an
operational definition of watching is
not provided to anyone in the household
so they have this thing that's supposed
to be measuring how they're watching but
they don't even really know like when
they're watching like what watching
means and the reason that that was okay
is because you know as long as the
ratings currency remains stable that's
more important you know the months
behind it if there's basis for the
negotiation the market can run but I
think now the digital data things are a
lot more visible and we can see that
well actually maybe be a better ways to
my attention so the next shortcut
assumption they kind of make is that a
passive audience is the best audience
these people deserve mesmerized by the
TV you know it's really it's really easy
I mean you kind of laugh but it's it
makes sense that this would be the
easiest thing to measure and this is a
quote from David Cole tracks who's the
chief research officer at CBS because we
all agree that the best technology the
totally passive system that doesn't
require any interaction with the viewer
and that's because as soon as the viewer
has to interact with it has to do
something there's you know you run the
risk that something is going to get
messed up and the data is going to be
accurate so they've sort of been pushing
toward more and more passive systems and
this next assumption goes along that one
hand in hand and this next assumption is
this a more scientific a method of
measurement the better it is so this is
actually from the 60s it's an
standing thing that they would put in
front of people's eyes and like watch
them watch television to see what was
happening and then come here is from a
an EEG study that was done in 2004 they
concluded your engagement highly couvert
in nature although it may have
observable behavioral correlates such as
direction of gays it is not itself
directly observable by others so
basically what they're saying here is
that you need to have some sort of
scientific mediator between the audience
and and you know the actual act of
engagement um because you know again
people themselves can't be trusted to to
you know express their own engagement in
in any kind of way so all of these
assumptions have given us this
operational definition of a television
audience they're really based on the
concept of exposure and that's that's
been paradigm really because all you
think measure is you know the person is
in the room with the TV the TV is on
that person has been exposed to TV
that's the best we can do is the best we
can give you that's the traditional way
the television audiences may have been
made valuable um and I want to push back
against that so I'm suggesting that we
move from exposure past the internet
ideas impression which is you know
basically another way of saying exposure
cute to an idea of expression and then
there are you know internet business
model obviously that take that into
account Chuck here is really just a
placeholder so we've got all different
kinds of expression going on obviously
there's you know fan expressions like
this like the Chuck example which is
very clear but because we're dealing
with with digital data there's now an
active expression every time someone
hits a button on the remote you know if
you choose to fast-forward a commercial
that's sending a message to the networks
on the advert
there's and that's all really valuable
information that can help them learn
more about their audiences um same thing
online with clicking obviously there are
a lot of business models that have
evolved around cost-per-click cost per
action those kind of models and if the
children industry you know needs to sort
of figure out how those are going to
work for their own business and now this
is sort of like what the value
reconfiguration looks like a mule out
there aren't really any arrows like same
house is going to work because that's
really the challenge that faces these
industries and that's what I go into in
more depth in my thesis um but basically
I'm saying these changes need to happen
soon because we're now in a position
where the cultural value of a Content
just isn't in line anymore of the
commodity value that's the network's
replace me on the audience now you know
I don't know if we've ever been able
distribution of the commodity value or
the cultural value that people get some
content but now it's just even more
parents that we're really not doing it
right because we can you know we can see
these visible manifestations because of
network culture um so is there a way to
measure and anticipate the cultural
value that people are going to get some
things so here are just some
recommendations and I like to I like to
use the term relevance audience and
instead of getting into the more like
nitty-gritty of exactly what you're
trying to deliver be sitting is going to
be different in every case so first I
suggest looking at fans only as a first
point of intervention because I think
flourish just you know give us the great
presentation about how fans are not
monolithic um and how fan behavior
doesn't necessarily reflect what the
rest of the audience is going to do I
think fans are a good place to start
because their behavior has always been
more visible and so good place to at
least get into understanding audience
expressions
the only way I'm use patterns is another
thing that digital data can tell us it
tells us how people are watching TV
again it might not tell us what value
they are getting from it but this kind
of behavioral data is is better than
just guessing and better than just
saying well you've been exposed to it so
it's must've worked and closely
following that is this idea of context
it's more than just how people are
watching this is also about where and
when I mean we can see that people were
able to stomach Jay Leno late at night
but got really mad when they moved him
to 10 yeah and that's you know that's
really an issue of contact that I mean
people you know should've just looking
at all along and I suppose but those are
things that you know we really can't
afford to forget again context might not
be able to tell us the cultural value of
content but it does help us know more
about viewers and then again I just want
to reemphasize this the relationships
here are really getting in the way the
way the industry is structured and I'm
suggesting that like these like really
cute baby animals everyone needs to be a
lot more flexible um willing to share
because data like everybody has so much
data now in guarding that data closely
isn't as important as it used to be
because the key challenge is making
sense of that data so sharing you know
as much as possible and trying to figure
that out is really going to be the way
to go moving forward and then the last
suggestion is to experiment the coolest
things about digital especially online
stuff it's that you can experiment in
real time that's almost real result real
time results I mean absolute legal does
they test their algorithm hundreds of
times a day and they make it better
every day and if you know you're able to
go in try
something doesn't work you can change it
really quickly and with little snow pops
once you've got your fixed cost covers
like digital distribution is is really
cheap and another cool thing about this
is that though the online space is
different from traditional television
the learnings they can get online can
really be applied back to television
since you know it's all digital
distribution so if you want to play
around in a space where you're not
making as much money and then you know
apply it back to regular TV I think that
that's the wisest strategy um and that
concludes my presentation a question
about this may be a dumb question but
when you talk about things like viewer
engagement and these cultural
this is cultural connection with
yeah their connection waited the content
it seems like a distinction for me
that's important economic station on my
xperia that it's been difference between
a content that is content and content
that is added and my engagement with
sailing and ad on TV cornell hulu or a
pre-roll ad on whatever it's different
than my game with the content and it
seems to be i know we've talked a little
well visit the ugly the ugly thing that
people have talked about is whether or
not engagement with the content actually
translates and frankly standing on a
game with the other thing and i'm not
sure what in your in your suggestions
now mediates that gap like I understand
to gap up like how understanding people
engaging with the content that is
content but what about the content that
is live and great like the subway right
well I mean that's always sort of sends
the question and I you really get into
impressions of advertising effectiveness
like does this actually work and that's
something that I don't maybe people
disagree with me if that's something
that I don't think anybody's moving to
specifically ever been able to answer so
then you get into more like nuanced
questions of branding
you exposure miles work really well for
branding you know you see something
everywhere it makes an impression on you
if that's all you want then it doesn't
really matter like how engage you are
with the content but then these changes
especially things like fast-forwarding
on that kind of thing is also given rise
to like the new era of product placement
Chuck again is a good example now they
pick you know because if this deal it's
that way there's a lot more subway in
Chuck's those kind of being integrated
into the content so then if you are
engaging with Chuck like you can't help
but see that Subway's also there and
whether or not that translates into
purchasing is another issue I'm should
you go into in tonight in my thesis
there's sort of an apush in the
advertising industry to you to get
single source data so like one provider
will tell tell them like from the point
of exposure like I saw a commercial to
the point of purchase i bought the thing
in the commercial they've been trying to
get that kind of data and there's been
some like huge huge notable failures on
that front to do it um so I mean I think
that I think that that kind of thing is
silly and that it should just be rican
sexualized and the advertisers really
need to say what do I want to get out of
my advertising right like is this about
exposure is it about branding or is it
about direct response which is something
that you can do more you know on the
internet with behavioral targeting you
can say oh you were just shopping for a
flight I'm going to like serve you an ad
about a flight you know that's directly
linked targeted to you and then I can
see if you actually buy the plate or did
you click on it or whatever so um
yeah i think that answer your question
yes question is like indeed if I'm
engaged with Chuck for example even at
subway he could be holding a subway
sandwich in the thing like if you want
to cut it across we're glad I'm not
necessarily engaged with the safe side
he's holding right so it seems like
there's always going yeah I mean there's
always a disconnect and that's what you
have is like an advertiser supported
medium and then obviously you can get
into the discussion of like are there
other business models that would better
suit this like you know subscription
models or something oh yes so think you
could expand on the difference between
ah the terms of content advertising like
you talk about all the scripted show us
so so non-scripted like Jay Leno is it
more specific to that kind of cryptid
show that he know who the audience
engagement was the same or is there
something like inheritance scripted
shows that caused people to be more
receptive advertising I mean in the case
of jay leno it wasn't i'm not really
talking about like engagement um I'm
just saying that like the ratings were
horrible and then there was like no one
watched it basically um which it's kind
of like well we're people the people you
know the five people who did watch it
were they engaged was that like does
that even matter um so I mean I guess
that like that's that's very interesting
question in it you know you do look at
I think that they tend to form around
scripted content more than around you
know reality shows although I guess it
depends on the reality show or other
kinds of like I don't know if there's
anything like talk show fandoms except
maybe Wendy Williams but that's really
cool different reason that's that's an
interesting question maybe for someone
in band study anyway there's this uh
brands hobbits there's yeah there's
quite pundit and there's like real
person
there's no
right as far as I know there's not a
giant reading what about the clinic yeah
they call it the kind of interesting
yeah yeah actually to all on the next
question it's amazing said you bring
their our last statement imagine it
without a different law I guess what I
was wondering if certainly I'm seeing
more and more movement of people buying
he be contacted by movies or books or
music and I know it's beyond your
segment is there a chance that Jesus
that I go in that direction of stopping
advertisement portico and yeah i think
that's that's sort of one of the huge
questions southern right now and
I I don't think so at least not yet and
because because of
because of these relationships like this
you know these are the people for making
the content and they have feel and
they're actually getting money from
everyone here is def Nielsen um so you
know it it's about more than just like
oh can we make a subscription all it's
about all of the feeds that everyone's
from cable subscriptions you
know from advertising and all those
deals and in syndication is another
issue syndication give you details
things like that so if you actually look
at the industry now it seems to be
stepping back from that we're hearing
more about authentication which is
something i actually do you talk about
in my paper so one of the ways they're
trying to make this relationship look
the same online as on TV if they're
saying ok you can watch TV online but
only if you already have a cable
subscription so it's kind of like we're
no more hulu like you can watch my show
if you already paid your cable provider
for it um in comcast and verizon have
already like rolled out these programs
where you have to go in and like
authenticate yourself I've improved that
now um that's not to say that a
subscription model may not take over
Apple has been working very hard because
right now the cost of buying individual
itunes shows and getting a season pass
for that is it costs more than like
and we box them DVDs so most people you
know how everything's opted that yet but
I mean I think that that really what
needs to happen again is experimentation
so you know these guys do have they can
go out and say like well what if we you
know what if we make achieve
subscription of like one show like let's
see if people buy it let's see people
like that better than you know these
authentication services are less you
know let's just see what happens and I
really think that now is the time to
figure that out before someone else to
juice it out and then you know disrupts
those people is very interesting and
maybe the last things I was a response
this last question to just that once I
could get rid of cable guy there and
everything by subscriptions a little
less no problem but until as long as
there's news lationship apart yeah I
think it some of it my questions
actually something else I I think that
it's great i mean in this idea that
we're moving from passive and exposure
and content as a measure of value to a
kind of active relationship thing it is
really useful and i keep things like
that I think there are historical
examples of this right i mean
shows that were cancelled were canceled
not just because ratings but because
people would buy the toys and so there
was that relationship already that what
was valued was not just people watching
but they actually had live stuff if it
wasn't selling the toys and it wasn't
wasn't working to this you know this is
kind of history prehistory to the
digital hopefully but i guess about my
personality then how do we think of that
relationship and I think that thing
about this too in terms of can we say
things to the content producers or the
network's even about piracy it gets them
to think differently right but I always
let the people pirating the stuff and
stimulating the law in advance I mean
I'm a are really great valuable groups
of people that they ought to be paying a
lot more attention to and saying yeah
it's not for your business model but
piece of people most committed to your
stuff an interesting new kind of way so
that's how I gotta think oh yeah but is
there something that your model says
okay now now you can see that the value
here that you've seen only as a loss
about yeah that's absolutely true and
I'm Henry his
about piracy as as a market failure
rather than you know it's not anything
other than a market failure you have
people who want your content who for
whatever reason can't get it obviously
they're going to be people who want
don't want to pay or don't want you to
go through channels whatever and are
going to pirates but I think that
percentage is actually really very small
yet we we actually just had a t3
research memo by healed comic about the
same thing where she was suggesting sort
of look at what pirates are doing and
say well what is it that they're getting
from the content that we're not getting
them so you know one of the big things
was well you know it's a file you can
keep and you know you can archive it and
you can also there's also more interplay
between devices so you can you know keep
Ireson and you can play it on your
computer you can play it on your phone
you don't have to worry about all the
drm and stuff so you know the fact that
piracy is happening and that's how
people are using it sort of suggests
well hey networks maybe if you made an
option like this available people might
want it and like I mean I heard how
cable subscription and even with TV
Everywhere I still can't watch it on
myself if I want to watch on my phone
apps download it and put it on so
big mr. Neilson
like nipping at his heels and besides
like Google Adwords what would I think
you talked about that maybe
I'm wondering where's Mallory's if we do
more to support because the ideas
I'm doing all this and maybe different
ways of measuring it well yeah I mean
the problem is that you've got like
different people measuring all this
stuff and Nielsen is also like trying to
measure it it's the things that I mean I
don't I don't think that right now
there's like a clear someone's going to
take this over but what I'm really
urging the industry to do here is to not
just replace meals and at Google but to
actually you know think more about this
relationship because you thought you
have some one year in a monopoly
position which which I didn't talk about
but I do talk about of my pieces that
you know it makes as a monopolist there
they're pretty slow to change they're
not there's there's no incentive for
them to be on the cutting edge of things
whereas if you look at a company like
the Google um you know in a increasingly
less competitive search market and
they're still doing things and innovate
and stay on topic that Nielsen just
haven't had attitude so I mean I would
suggest not just putting a new mediator
in but like figuring that out
we I have bonus like I'm sure you guys
they have like 0
this is my biology boys quickly replied
of every well because I'm like using a
lot of like Marxism but I want a job the
industry so we got like Marxism elegant
economic theory is not like antithetical
to to making money at all it's just a
way to describe power dynamics but I
think a lot of people your arms compare
like oh my god your communist but like
no